you guys ready
good evening i'm captain dory corn with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i currently oversee our homicide sex
crimes and abuse neglect sections and
tonight i'm here to brief you on a
homicide that involved multiple victims
at 8 30 pm this evening
we received a 911 call regarding a
shooting
that happened inside of a hotel room
near the 3400 block of las vegas
boulevard
the initial details indicated that three
people had been shot and that one of
them was deceased
our officers immediately responded
they actually arrived on scene with
approximately within about a minute of
the initial call
and then what they discovered was that
three people had been shot one of them
was deceased our officers immediately
began providing medical attention so did
security personnel
the two other persons had been shot were
immediately transported to umc hospital
and then we immediately began securing
the scene as we normally do on a
shooting like this
it's still early into the investigation
we're still determining exactly what
happened but we can tell you at least
preliminarily
that we there was an altercation that
happened in the room between four
individuals we believe all known to each
other
we believe it was an isolated incident
that happened inside of the room
and that during that altercation one
individual ended up shooting three other
individuals
the other two individuals that were
transported are adult females
they are in critical condition or shot
multiple times
and then the other
deceased unfortunately he's a male
victim
right now we are asking the public as we
normally do on any types of incident
like this if you have any information
related to this incident please call
crime stoppers
and provide any information you can
and i'll just kind of add just one note
which is
these types of incidents any types of
extreme violence that happens in our
city we take very seriously you've seen
it with all the investigations we
conduct
we're fortunate to have the best
homicide investigative unit in the
country with the highest clearance rates
for a reason so we're confident we will
solve this case
the suspect is currently outstanding
uh we believe he is a black male adult a
little heavier set
but we do have good information good
leads that we're working and as i said
we have a lot of confidence that we will
catch
the killer in this case and we will uh
close this investigation as we always do
other than that it's uh there's no other
disruption to the las vegas strip or any
other area right now we've limited any
kind of traffic closures initially the
response required some you know
extra police presence because we were
still trying to figure out exactly what
occurred but at this time there should
be really nothing visible or disruptive
to the general public and no further
threat at this time that we believe uh
is you know opposed to the general
public with that i have time for a few
questions then we've got to get back to
the investigation
so adult male approximately i believe
40s or 50s
were these people visiting town or do
they happen to live here
we don't know if they currently live
here but there is a local nexus we're
not we're not certain exactly if they've
revisited or
but there is a local address is
associated to at least one of the
individuals
on the eighth floor
so as of now we we've secured off a
variety of areas because we're still
trying to determine exactly where the
entire crime scene is but uh we're
confident to say it was isolated inside
of a room
in one of the properties there
have you guys talked to the surveillance
department is there surveillance cameras
within that hallway
you know what at this time we're still
exploring all investigative leads that
includes picking up all of the
surveillance data that we potentially
could get but i will point out that
we've
the security personnel and our
partnerships in general all across the
strip have been remarkable uh not just
in in this case uh but all the all the
incidents that we've had on las vegas
strip we have a great partnership with
all of our hotel partners in this
particular case uh security was hand in
hand working with us from the very
beginning making this a very effective
investigation and a lot of credit goes
to them and our officers for the
immediate response time to be here
within a minute of a shooting happening
and to be able to provide medical
attention could make a difference
potentially for the other victims when
you say a minute is that just to the
front doors or to the actual room itself
i'm not sure exactly but i can tell you
that uh within a minute of the call
coming in a 9-1-1 call we had officers
already announcing that they're arriving
on scene uh that may be the initial
property or maybe in the elevators not
really sure i just have maybe one or two
more questions
you know what i think that the public
here has a lot of confidence in their
police department and so when they saw
our officers arriving pretty quickly and
handling business i think that reassured
everyone and kept things calm and helped
same thing for the security personnel i
think they were able to maintain calm
and uh we didn't see any major
disruptions fortunately
i'm sorry
my name oh sure my name is dory corrin
d-o-r-i
k-o-r-e-n
the captain over our homicide sex crimes
bureau thank you folks i appreciate it
unfortunately we have to get right back
to the investigation but thank you guys
have a good night